so Zayn is developing a new TV series
based on his experience in one direction
have you heard that news I'll be
interesting I know what do you make of
that
uh nothing suppose nothing surprises me
anymore no no I think you should have
come to me with it but being honest with
you I was going to say do you feel like
do you does the show or the project have
your blessing I wouldn't say blessing I
just think they should come to me with
these things first because I probably
gonna cast someone as a Simon Cowell
character right who knows
I always said but I do actually believe
that when they've got these ideas
bearing in mind where we started they
should actually come to me who created
these shows quickly right but do you are
you surprised you but are you surprised
that Zayn arguably the widest member in
the group not only broke up on his own
but is now producing and doing a
television series like I said nothing
surprised me look I like everyone who's
got ambition but I'm not gonna lie
there's always part of me that things
should give it to me
you